[Music]
it's easy to see why fans are falling
for Jonah Marais but did you know that
there's more to the singer than meets
the eye watch until the end to find out
what the pop stars looking for in his
next girlfriend new to the things don't
forget to hit that subscribe button for
more entertainment to come your way oh
and if you love Jonah as much as we do
make sure to give this video a big
thumbs up
now let's unravel some of Jonah's
deepest secrets all in good fun of
course he loves his fans without
dedicated fans most pop stars wouldn't
have the opportunity to go on tour and
achieve their dreams
luckily for Jonah he's got more than
enough fans were willing to support him
while some celebrities will go to great
lengths to escape their fans while out
in public the same can't be said about
Jonah instead the young pop star makes
it a point to take pictures with his
followers and even give some big hugs
whenever they asked on many accounts
done' has used his bustling social media
platforms to thank his fans for their
support he's made it known that without
them he'd still be singing in the shower
instead of on stage we think it's super
sweet that the wide don't remeber runs
towards his fans instead of away from
them he's a social media sensation when
it comes to having an online presence
some might say that Jonah has quickly
become the king of social media in fact
there isn't a day that goes by that the
young pop star doesn't share a comment
or two on his Twitter account while he
tends to tweet about virtually anything
he's also known for dropping some killer
advice to his fans on October 12th 2018
Jonah posted everything you've ever
wanted is right outside your comfort
zone and his words ring true with
thousands of people the social media
sensation is constantly upping his
online game and it's clear to us that
his fans are loving every second of it
do you follow Jonah on Twitter and
Instagram if not it's safe to say that
you're missing out his clothing style
it's easy to see that Jonah enjoys
dressing himself up to the nines which
is why we're not surprised to find out
that he has a secret sock addiction when
it comes to style knowing can say a
thing against the star and this is
because his outfit sir
always on point Jonah is souped up from
head to toe and he enjoys a collection
of funny and funky socks to slip into in
fact it's rare to see him wearing a pair
of plain socks because well they don't
exist in his wardrobe on top of that the
American sensation also loves wearing
plaid pants and oversized hoodies so all
in all Jonah's fashion style is
laid-back with a hint of flare donut
enjoy showing off his style on his
Instagram accounts and we don't blame
him he didn't always sing in a group
Jonah knew that he wanted to be a star
from a young age but like everyone else
he didn't exactly know where to start so
to launch his career he took to posting
videos on You Now which allowed him to
gain a following
before long he linked up with social
media stars Nash Brier and Cameron
Dallas and made his first appearance at
the prestigious dizzy Tour event in 2014
Jonah's solo career was quickly taking
off and he began releasing singles left
right and center however the solo artist
soon realized that something was missing
which prompted him to join the
up-and-coming boy band
why don't we and well the rest is pretty
much history in the end this decision
kick started his career in the right
direction
and Jonah hasn't looked back since he's
obsessed with Harry Potter anyone born
in the late 80s and 90s grew up
alongside the Harry Potter series these
amazing books and films inspired
millions of children to think outside
the box and Jonah was one of them the
star admitted to being a huge Harry
Potter fan on a number of social media
platforms and when a fan asked him which
house he'd want to be a part of the
singer answer that he'd be in Gryffindor
no matter what he also went on to state
that if he'd gone to Hogwarts he would
have helped Harry Hermione and Ron beat
the Dark Lord so if he thought that
Jonah couldn't get any cuter you were
wrong if you're a Harry Potter fan let
us know which house you'd want to get
sorted into in the comments he wants a
girlfriend
Jonah might be a celebrity but he does
enjoy keeping his personal life a secret
for this reason it's hard to find out
whether or not the star has a girlfriend
or not
however on more than one account he's
tweeted about wanting a girlfriend and
being tired of being single while his
actions led us to believe that he's been
watching Harry Potter alone
he's been rumored to have dated
Instagram model Tatum doll however when
we take a look at his Instagram account
there isn't a picture of the couple in
sight so knowing mists were confident
that Jonah is single and ready to mingle
want to find out what the star is
looking for and his dream girl for
watching till the end to find out and
believe us when we say that the truth
might shock you he's a joker there are
many reasons why Jonah loves being a
part of why don't we and one of them is
that he gets to hang out with his
bandmates on a regular basis although he
may seem like a serious guy Jonah is
somewhat of a joker and his favorite
person to laugh with is Corbin Besson
these two friends will go to extreme
lengths to make each other laugh when
they're not supposed to jonah admitted
via instagram that his mission is to get
corbin to crack up during meet and
greets and he seems to be accomplishing
this task since keeping a straight face
during filmed events is a must the van
mates purposely toy with each other in a
friendly manner so next time you see a
picture of corbin and jonah know that
they're doing their best to hide their
grins he's only 20 years old it's hard
to believe that success can be achieved
at such a young age but it's the truth
this is made obvious by the fact that
jonah is only twenty years old and
already has a record deal the celebrated
artist is well on his way to becoming a
member of the best boy band in America
but he doesn't let that get to his head
Jonah was born on June 16 1998 making
him a Gemini the quirky singers
astrology sign matches his personality
to a tee after all he is both a reserved
person and a public figure which is a
little contradicting despite his young
age Jonah has managed to reach star
status and there's no way of knowing how
high he will climb the star spends his
20th birthday performing on stage and he
wouldn't have it any other way he loves
sports some people are lucky to be born
with one single talent but Jonah isn't
most people the superstar has a plethora
of skills and he isn't afraid to pursue
them while it's uncommon for artistic
people to enjoy playing sports there's
nothing ordinary at
the why don't we band member before
pursuing his music career Jonah used to
play baseball in his spare time on top
of that he enjoys watching professional
basketball it's no secret that Jonah is
the athletic type however he seems to
have put sports on the back burner for
the mean time due to his hectic schedule
but once things calm down there's no
doubt in our minds that Jonah will
return to his roots
for now the singer is keeping fit by
going to the gym and keeping an eye on
his nutrition but he stated that eating
healthy is the hardest part
he's a small-town boy who cries during
movies although Jonah's style and
personality might scream Hollywood this
isn't where the star was born believe it
or not but the why don't we band member
hails from Stillwater Minnesota which is
a super small town in America being from
a small town impacted the star in many
different ways but none of them are
negative donut was raised to embrace his
emotions instead of repression them
which is why he's deemed himself the
most emotional member in his boy band
Jonah went on to add that it takes a
real man to cry and later admitted to
being a sucker for sad movies although
hard to believe the singer has a hard
time keeping his eyes dry while watching
movies with sad scenes and we don't
blame him after all it's important for
everyone to be in touch with their
sensitive side his tattoos it's rare to
meet someone who doesn't have a tattoo
these days however these people are out
there since most people only get inked
later in life it's normal for the
younger crowd to be tattoo free back in
2016
Jonah posted a tweet saying that he
wanted to get a super dope tattoo and
now nearly three years later the singer
has free tats to his name his latest
tattoo is a reminder of home which is
why it's shaped to resemble the
Minnesota state to add some Flair Jonah
got some of his hometown landmarks drawn
into the shape and he couldn't be
happier with the outcome Jonah also has
a tattoo on his shoulder and a palm tree
on his forearm which one of his tats do
you like best he's from a big family
back in the day families that had under
4 children were considered small but
today families at
more than two kids are considered
significant although people aren't
choosing to have fewer children that
didn't stop Jonah's parents from having
four of their own the celebrity has two
sisters
Esther Grace and Spain and one brother
tubulin despite being incredibly
successful Jonah has admitted that his
parents aren't the most supportive a
since he had to leave school to pursue
his dreams while moving away caused a
rift between him and his family Jonah
has put those hard times in the past and
now considers himself a family man while
Jonah might not be a high school
graduate he is living his dream and he's
happy with his decisions never know have
you ever wondered which one of the why
don't we songs is Jonah's all-time
favorite well if you have you're about
to get the answer by now we all know
that Jonah is a sensitive guy which is
why we're not surprised to find out that
his favorite song is never know the star
relates to this hit because it reminds
him of everything he had to go through
to get to where he is today in his own
words
it describes going after your dream
whatever that may be since Jonah had to
leave his family and school behind to
achieve his goals he knows a thing or
two about sacrifice
so next time you listen to never know
you'll be able to understand it on a
whole new level
he's Ed Sheeran's number one fans ed
Sheeran is one of the best artists on
the market the Hollywood sensation has
been raising the bar for other artists
ever since he first stepped foot on the
stage ed is an inspiration for many
struggling singers and while it might be
hard to believe he was once Jonah's
number one favorite celebrity when it
comes to idols don't admirers people who
stayed true to the revision and produce
original music for this reason he has
also embraced posts Malone's career via
Twitter while there's no way of knowing
if Jonah will be as successful as his
idols something tells us that he might
just have what it takes what he looks
for in a girl
so you've made it to the end of our
video and you'd like to find out what
Jonah looks for in a girl
well for starters it goes without saying
that attraction needs to be present but
when asked which quality his future
girlfriend would need to have don't
immediately stated that a great
personality
is key from what we gather Jonah can't
fall
in love with someone who he can't have a
great conversation with and can you
really blame him in the end looks will
fade and personality will prevail
so we hope you found out everything you
wanted to know about why don't we Dona
before you go though let us know which
one of the Bands songs is your favorite
and why and that's the end of our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]